Well,
Susan,
pseudonym gear for,
well,
you know,
it's,
it's really interesting when it comes to data when it comes to diet because you
know,
the,
the whole throw the baby out with the bath bath water thing or one of the
studies that I've read pretty recently,
it was about um,
the amount of people that suffered ill health consequences that ate red meat
five days per week versus people who didn't.
But what they didn't take into account was what the people ate with the red meat
when they drank soda.
Whether what,
how did you get your form of red meat?
Was it grass fed beef?
Was it bison or wild game or was it a burger from Wendy's with fries and a sugar
been and all the,
the,
the bullshit that people eat along with the food and that you,
you literally,
and people would cite these things as being evidence that something is negative
for you,
that red meat is negative for you,
but you're not taking into consideration all the things that we're eating with
that red meat.
So these studies that come out like that there are,
so they're,
they're really annoying because it's like you have to,
you usually he talked to people about it.
You have to like sit down with them.
Okay,
sit down.
this is a long process.
Yeah.
Like try to try to figure out what is the cause of these issues.
When you're talking about a lifetime of abuse,
you're talking about like all sorts of different health consequences of a
variety of different foods and you're attributing it all to one part of your
diet and that's very difficult to do unless you,
you've isolated everything else and done a bunch of different studies where
okay,
I ate nothing but fruits and vegetables and I eat really healthy and I read meet
five days a week or I nothing but shit and fries and buns and pasta and I didn't
eat red meat at all and now here's the result.
Right.
You're making a really good point.
And that is the combination of how these different foods are interacting in our
bodies.
Extremely important.
Like we talked about the refined sugar and saturated fat Combo.
Well,
you know,
the,
the read me and even just,
you know,
a protein like itself,
like,
you know,
essential amino acids that are coming from animal protein itself and how that is
interacting with,
you know,
eating,
eating a terrible diet like refined sugar,
which is causing damage to ourselves.
You know,
also exercise.
And this is something really,
um,
the,
the protein,
uh,
exercise things seems to be really key.
But there was a recent study that was published that was the largest study
observational study done so far looking at um,
protein intake and all cause mortality and cancer mortality.
And it found like a lot of other studies that higher protein consumption,
um,
higher meat,
protein consumption from meat was associated with a higher all cause mortality
in a higher cancer mortality.
But then when the data was sub analyzed and,
and,
and other unhealthy style factors will looked at.
So,
so,
um,
if,
if someone had one other unhealthy lifestyle factor being either obesity,
smoking,
excessive alcohol consumption or being sedentary,
then they had a higher,
they were,
had a higher all cause mortality in a higher cancer mortality if they meet.
But guess what,
if they had zero,
none of those other unhealthy lifestyle factors,
they didn't have,
they had the same aisle all cause mortality and cancer related mortality that
they're not eating meat,
meat eater it's had.
So I think that really highlights the importance of other lifestyle factors.
Other foods,
you know,
that's really important when we're at,
when we're looking at these observational studies,
when you were talking about saturated fat and the negative consequences of
eating refined sugar with saturated fat,
is there a negative,
um,
uh,
corresponding negative consequence?
Like if you had a,
if you had negative or if you had,
um,
uh,
an,
a dye that didn't have any saturated fat in it,
but you ate refined sugar,
like say if you eat a vegan diet,
does saturated or does um,
refined sugar have less of an impact
of eating?
So,
so the refined sugars,
the LDL,
it's an issue with fat.
Yeah,
I think eight.
Yes.
So the LDL will go down if you're eating a Vegan diet diet,
and even though you're still eating cookies or some whatever,
begin stuff,
fine.
Sugar's probably like less dangerous to someone.
On a Vegan Diet.
Does that?
Yes,
I think so.
And,
and the thing,
the thing with that is,
is that if you look at,
but if you look at refined sugar,
also refined sugar is associated with heart disease risk.
In fact it's like one of the,
and there was a big,
big study like 400,000 different individuals looked at refined shirt,
people that had the highest up refined sugar intake.
But again,
saturated fats,
a confounding factor there,
right,
had like a four times higher risk of getting a heart,
having a heart attack.
But it's,
it's perfect.
You illustrated it perfectly.
And that is,
and that's where I think a lot of these guidelines like the American heart
association come from.
If you are on a population level,
if you say to someone reduce your saturated fat intake,
you're going to lower the LDL risk.
And regardless of all the other stuff they're doing,
you know,
it,
it probably,
well on a population level,
lower their heart disease risk,
but on an individual level,
like someone like you and I,
we don't eat all that other stuff.
You know,
we were very health conscious and do all these things.
You and I,
if we stopped our saturated fat intake,
likely,
you know,
for me I guess my jeans are a little different but likely wouldn't have the same
effect.
So if you were to take that same population to people and say,
okay,
eat your saturated fat,
but take out the refined sugar,
we may see the same thing where the,
where the heart disease risk goes down just like it does.
Men with saturated fat.
In fact,
there've been studies where replacement foods have done,
have looked at,
um,
replacement foods for saturated fat.
And if you replace saturated fat with refined sugar,
it does not,
um,
lower the risk of a heart disease.
So basically that's,
that's kind of a proof of principle there.
But I do think that it's,
it's,
it's an important point and it's something that the American Heart Association
there,
they're now starting to at least mentioned the small dense LDL.
So I think that moving in that direction is good because it means that possibly
then,
you know,
over the next decade we're going to start to see,
okay,
now we got to start.
It's not just the LDL.
I'm confused about something you just said.
You said if you replace saturated fat with refined sugar,
if you replace the saturated fat with refined sugar,
eat,
if you,
sorry,
refined carbohydrates,
which I usually think of as refined sugar,
refined carbohydrates.
Um,
it does not.
So the idea is of saturated fat was so bad.
If you replaced,
if you took the saturated fat and replace it with a refined carbohydrate,
it would lower the risk of heart disease.
And it does.
It doesn't,
it doesn't lower the risk.
All right,
so,
so basically,
so it's not the saturated fats,
the saturated fat along with refined sugar that has some sort of a negative
synergistic effect.
That's what,
that's what the data in aggregation,
looking at the clinical trials,
looking at the mechanism,
looking at the observational studies and look and understanding the interaction
of all these foods together.
When the American Heart Association puts out sort of a blanket statement like
that.
Yeah.
A lot of people take it as fact.
And then what my research has shown my reading rather,
I shouldn't say research,
I'm a dummy,
but the the people that I've read who have criticized this,
there are actually scientists and researchers,
they have a huge issue with that statement.
They think that this is just,
it's too simplistic.
It's not taking into account all the various nuances in genetics,
diet,
ancestry,
all the different factors.
But people read that and it's sort of like this cookie cutter approach and then
they paired it out to everybody else.
Yeah,
it's true.
I mean that's,
that's exactly what happens.
And that same thing goes with,
with the protein and it being bad as well.
And there's all sorts of nuances and the combination of the protein with the,
with the bad diet and also the exercise,
which is one of the,
one of the things with the,
with the protein is that it increases IGF one and IGF one is a growth factor and
it can allow B cells that are damaged that should otherwise die,
not die.
And so it can allow us precancerous cells to form a tumor.
And that's,
we know that from mechanistic studies and you know that's,
that's kind of a big part of the,
the,
the eating protein essential amino acids specifically or what does it do do
this.
And they are,
they're found an animal protein.
And that sort of the big argument there,
but there's also this whole argument where if you are one exercising the IGF one
goes into your brain,
it's been shown across the blood brain barrier.
It goes into your brain and also on your muscle where it grows new neurons in
the brain and actually repairs damaged,
damaged muscle tissue and helps grow muscle tissue,
which is also an a predictor of,
of all cause mortality.
So you know,
the x,
again,
the exercise comes in there.
And then also the fact that if you're eating a good diet and you're not,
you're not causing as much damage to happen in the first place,
then those growth factors being there aren't as big of a deal because you don't
have all these damaged cells from all this refined sugar you're eating that can
basically become cancerous cells.
So that's kind of,
you know,
with that study of the observational study that looked at people that were
eating me,
if they didn't have any of those unhealthy lifestyle factors,
guess what?
They're all cause mortality and cancer mortality was the same as the
vegetarians.
And I think that's kind of highlighting that,
that,
that issue,
you know.